the stockbrokers battalion was comprised
of men from the city of london and so it
was a very homogenous group who came
together in late August of 1914 when war
broke out people in the banking sector
and stock market were immediately
involved because the plan which had been
laid some years before for what to do
when they war starts required the
closure of banks and stock market to
prevent a run on both so suddenly bank
holiday on the Monday war on the Tuesday
they were an unusual group in that they
were one of the first in fact the first
group of friends to come together as a
battalion previously you joined the
territorials you'd been a Saturday
soldier you had some experiences
they then went off to war they weren't
in the first of the worst of the
fighting but they were in some pretty
tough fighting and they lost a lot of
men in the process of the thousand and
one hundred or so who officially signed
up and were in colchester in the camp
about 900 of them went across to France
on July the 31st of that 900 about a
third were killed the bankers were very
keen to participate they wanted to be
there it wasn't that they've been forced
in a lot of them when the war finished
simply picked up their lives they they
wanted to some of them have got married
some of them wanted to get married so
they did to a certain extent brush the
dust off their bowlers brush the dust
off their traveling portmanteaus and
just pick up their lives and go on